love this guy he's one of my favorite
people not just because i love his work
but i feel like i grew up with a guy
like this nine perfect strangers on hulu
premiered yesterday new episodes
released weekly on wednesdays only on
hulu the great bobby canavali here on
the rich eisen show how are you sir
hello rich
buddy let me tell you yes you're very
lucky you didn't get me five minutes ago
i when i was looking for a parking space
but i found one
and you know what where are you positive
i'm not positive like this guy's not
coming back but i think i'm okay i think
we're okay where are you are you in
manhattan looking for parkinson's no i'm
at home i'm in brooklyn i'm in brooklyn
we got to move the car you know
alternate side of the street parking
street cleaning and stuff like that so
so did you find a spot that's good for
at least two more days bobby or what
we're good i didn't because i was like
if i keep on looking for a spot i found
a spot where i'd have to move it in the
morning but at least it's a spot because
if i was trying to look for a spot while
we were talking about really important
stuff you know um it would it might be
messy so extra are we are we in danger
of getting a tick are you getting the
ticket or what like oh no i'm not in
data getting a ticket i mean you know
i'm just you know i'm like i might have
said a couple things to somebody
so they're not moving fast enough were
they sitting in the car like texting or
something when you want to get out like
like maybe like a guy from the
neighborhood maybe was trying to save
the spot but i was like oh
that's no no no no no we we cannot have
a move
we cannot have that add-on
was he still like i am looking
so you are looking behind my feet you
know that's the thing about covered time
with these interviews is like here i am
in my car right yes but i literally have
to be look around to look over my
shoulder it could be interesting
so because that's
that's untenable somebody was literally
like physically standing in the spot for
somebody else to come back around and
you are there that's not that's that's
that's animal you can't do that that's
that's like you can't do that you can't
you know what you could probably do that
in like um
like like literally thousands of other
places in the country brooklyn new york
and you can't really do that no like you
you can't you can't do that so and
obviously you knew i wasn't obsessed
i'm fascinated by this stuff since now i
live in a place where you just valet and
screw it doesn't matter anymore so uh so
um so so what's yours what's your style
bobby cannavale when somebody is in a
spot
and you saw them get in the car
and they did not give you the wave of
like i'm staying here so you now have
communicated verbal non-verbally with
this person that they're getting out
but yeah they're not moving fast enough
what do you do do you put the signal on
in front do you go
in front of them do you sit behind them
wait for them to get out what do you do
now what happens next i give it i i give
it a couple minutes and then i you know
i assume
privately and then i and then i pull up
very slowly yeah give him the dead look
the dead looking dead-eyed face
from you that's got to get some results
though bobby they they move yeah
you bring out the gyproceeti belt that's
what you do right you get out of the car
you bust out the belt i mean they move
hey look if that works for me in my
lifetime if it works for me because of
that part three times that's three times
more than a person that people want it's
a parking spot it is worth it
it's something
bobby cannavale here on the rich eisen
show all right so you're now you're now
so just one more second on this visual i
can't get enough of it so you're now
parked are you parked in this space
right now
in the space
i kind of wish i could show you because
the one of the funny things about it was
that the guy was like bro you ain't
gonna fit in here anyway and then that's
all i needed to hear i kind of wish this
was all alive because i was like i'm not
gonna fit in there i'm not gonna fit in
there i'm like have you seen me you know
you know this car you've seen this car
right i mean i could pull into anything
i could pull into any spot
and it's very tight but i'm in
oh my god because right now if you are
sitting in the car you might have to
give the look to somebody else saying
i'm not moving you might have to give
the finger wave right that's how you do
it right or do you do the full hand you
shake your head what do you do i do no
eye contact finger wave
no eye contact you won't even know what
eye contact i'm busy here single wave
across the car
bobby carnevale here on the rich eisen
show
i mean the visual you need the visual if
you got it you understand well here's
what i want here's what i want when
we're done i want a shot of the front
and the back i want what are we like two
and a half inches in the bumpers
how tight are we what do you got a
couple inches i'm gonna text it to you
i'll text you right after we're done and
then you've got my permission to show it
okay very good
show off bobby connor he this must be an
aces
parallel parking job if he is ready to
if he is ready
oh if he's doing it twice a week
obviously we are proud of it yeah okay
fantastic top-notch parallel parking
bobby canavali here on the rich eisen
show uh how about those yanks bobby huh
how about this team i mean out of
nowhere
this is a good time to win to start
winning yeah it's good that's like
they've hit it i guess if they do they
would do and they're doing it but let's
not talk too much about it oh i know but
i mean the fact that they're in
i don't know man here's
here's the reason why i'll talk about it
because in in the first half of the
season like i don't know if you saw last
night's game or not but i'm i'm watching
every pretty much every pitch these days
last night they put a four spot on the
red sox to help them essentially win it
and in the inning they got um they got a
two out base hit two run two out base
hit they got a sac fly uh from third
they got a stolen base
these are things that just didn't exist
in the first half of the season that did
not exist they're they're like alive
they went from the most boring team to
the most exciting team in one month i've
i really haven't seen something like
this it's unbelievable to be fair like
guys that are supposed to be hitting
even you know are finally hitting like
guys that like
it wasn't making sense that they
wouldn't weren't hitting like dj like
even luke voight like you've been back
already for a while let's go like he
please putting it together you know
uh those guys are um
are finally hitting right so they are
and i know i'm sure you you know a bunch
of cubs fans the fact that the yankees
plucked rizzo from them and he's been so
friggin phenomenal and he looks the part
he looks like he should be a yankee the
rest of his life he looks like he's out
of that he looks like he's out of that
o'neill mode you know like he should
never leave the bronx again it's killing
all the cubs fans killing them killing
them right now it is right now yeah i
know i know they're they're they they
are awful uh they can't they can't they
can't not mention it right it's great i
mean we have a guy who's a die hard you
know from the south side of chicago and
he's just the rizzo thing is really uh
it's like [ __ ] dent or something
i love it it's that solemn a voice oh
boy i love it um so uh where are you did
you hear about the jets today bobby did
you hear about it i know you might be a
busy man but
the uh we
forfeit the first game no
[Laughter]
no we lose the game no
no we have not lost yet carl lawson who
they picked up from the bengals who's
been killing it defensively he's was
carted off with an apparent achilles
injury it looks very bad
that guy
out it looks like all right
wow well at least you got the parking
spot right
yeah i got the parking spot and at least
you know at least saleh looks like he's
been hitting the gym he does
he does like he's been pumping
definitely a little more than cos these
guys how about these fans that are like
i don't know i like that soleil i'm like
you like him because he looks like the
rock and everybody loves the rock
it could be that you know you say he's
like aspirational you know like we kind
of want to look like him a little bit
you know after the parade of coaches
we've had before him
you know he kind of wins he's like the
hottest one i'm just wondering if the
jets have
he might be the first health nut they've
had at uh at coaching uh since maybe
like herm you know he looks like he's
like a guy who's into making sure he's
okay you know like rex never was that
guy he wanted a snack yeah right all
right no case case looked like he needed
you know some you know help where are
you on your fantasy where are you on
your fantasy right now bobby cannavale
i'm in the middle of my best ball draft
right now and our draft a regular draft
is coming up but i'm you know joe lo jo
you know joey stacks joel with trulia
yes he's got us on this best ball third
year in a row he's won it's the first
two years and it's we know we're just
giving him our money we think it's a fix
but you know gambling is like bad but
it's hard not to so what is he doing
come on 200 bucks throw it in and you
did you just do it and uh but best balls
kind of fun although there's nothing to
do except you just draft and then you
just leave the team alone right right
okay so and so and then at the end you
know you don't have to like set your
roster you just pick a bunch of guys and
let it roll so when's
when's the draft the actual fantasy
draft and i assume you have not changed
your fantasy team name correct
i'm just a tip
forever forever
um
uh yeah that's coming up you know like
labor day weekend like everybody else
okay all right and so you haven't picked
our order yet you know but you don't
have to worry i don't think i'll be
drafting any jets this year no i don't
know man i mean you never know but so uh
okay so you've got um you don't know
what pick your is it totally randomized
is it uh what is it
you get keeping anybody
it's not a keeper league it's not
anything like that it's just a regular
snake draft and we're we just haven't
picked the order yet we got to do it you
know rudd is in that league yeah he's
busy so he's in london any he's overseas
yeah man yeah yeah
um so so but it's going to be some time
around them well but yeah we should be
picking the order okay how do you just i
just i just road tripped across the
country i just got back literally
yesterday and uh and i thought i was
going to read like i brought john
steinbeck's grapes of wrath i was like
uh first time ever i'm 51 i'm taking
this trip i'm going to read grapes of
wrath all i read was mike was the newest
fantasy football
you know like
magazine i got like the you know the
special edition fantasy football i was
in poor steinbeck just stopped there i
uh did my fantasy football research for
eight years
it should be i have good intentions you
know bobby you don't need to grow any
more than you already have you're a
grown man what else you need i know you
don't need this you don't need that sort
of steinbeck you need to make sure that
you are going to be you know taking care
of your fantasy team
all right so yes all right do we know
what rut do we know what rudd's name is
yet or we don't know that yet because
that's always a dr he changes his name
every year he changes it he changes it a
lot yeah okay um you don't know it yet
yeah all right yeah yeah how'd you do on
the side
you know how'd you do in your fantasy
league with nicole kidman and michael
shannon and uh melissa mccarthy and the
rest of the crew was there nine perfect
strangers fantasy league there were
there wasn't i mean well all of us felt
like we hit the lottery because we were
shooting it in uh you know byron bay
australia which in australia i have a
close relationship with it now because
of my life but uh i go a lot but i've
never been in that part of the country
and it's like paradise and we went you
know in july of last year you know we
were really lucky so everybody was just
just so thrilled to be in a place that
had no cobit it was very strange like
being on another planet no
no masks no lines i mean we were matched
up while we were shooting there were
protocols but there wasn't any covet
anywhere now you know having a hard time
now they're trying to lock it down right
but really that was our that was the big
that was the big big win for that show
because that was with the shooting la
and they ended up moving into australia
in the middle of the pandemic and you
know it was a
good thing to escape well how how do you
how do you like how it's turned down
bobby it's starting out i'm good man
yeah it's pretty good you know i uh
got michael shannon in it he's an eight
he's like an all-time favorite and uh
luke evans and regina hall and really
fun cast and
uh and i do like it i have to say like
right you're right i'm not getting out
[Laughter]
imagine if i rolled the window down and
i was like hey i'm talking about my tv
show that's right talking about you're
doing press you're doing press i'm doing
press what are you doing
um if that's your neighborhood shouldn't
they recognize you
right yeah they know he's doing press
it's like all he does is take he's look
for spots and do press it's like in
trading places when that woman rolled up
on clarence beaks when he was using the
pay phone and he had a little word for
exactly exactly exactly
it dropped last night and i think it's
good man it's really good you know it's
got david kelly wrote it and you know
it's a pretty good team it's the same
people brought you big little lies same
writers um and you know it's intriguing
and i think nicole is fantastic in it
and
i don't know man you know i think uh
thematically it's the sort of right kind
of show for right now you know it's
about a bunch of people thrown together
in this wellness retreat and they're
dealing with all kinds of trauma and
grief and
and we come to find out that they're
being treated pretty unorthodox you know
in a pretty unorthodox manner and uh and
that's i think a really
cool surprise one of the reasons i liked
it was because you know i was interested
in that kind of thing like alternative
therapy let's call it
and um and it's pretty suspenseful along
the way so yeah i think it's because i
think it's a good one i don't think i
wouldn't be here i'd just be texting you
on this side
she wouldn't be calling me
from your fresh parking spot there in
brooklyn nine perfect strangers
premiered yesterday new episodes
released weekly on wednesdays only on on
hulu you're the best bobby man i just
laughed my ass off every time we chat
oh my gosh i love it love it i love
hearing your voice go yankees baby
see now you're into it you don't don't
worry about it we're it's it's it's
definitely improved and there
there's a light there's a pulse there's
more than a pulse it's unbelievable
i don't remember anything like this with
the yankees it's been great i think it's
a good time for it to be happening yeah
it's good better than november i know
hey you take care of yourself bobby uh
get out of the car i don't want any more
i don't know you know we just want to
make sure everything's fine and broken
you know
the pick yeah send me the photos i want
to see it please front and back front
and back all right thanks buddy bobby
cannavale everybody he's getting out of
his car hey buddy he's gonna take the
front
what do you think it's gonna be tight
tight again i don't know what type of
car that says he said he can fit into
any spot so i'm guessing it's uh it's a
small guy but at bobby underscore
kanavali on instagram not getting out
i'm excited i'm not getting out
see if he's supposed to open i'm just
dying can we just take a break and get
these
he did a selfie with the car behind him
they're like shaw closely oh my god
is good
people on twitter are saying this is
photoshopped it is not he literally just
sent this to us
and his text to me was come on who's
more butter than me
and it looks like he needed to put
butter on his front and back bumpers in
order to get in that spot and you can't
blame his neighbor for saying you're not
getting anywhere absolutely but if i am
a neighbor and i'm saying you're not
getting in here and i know brooklyn and
i know new york city his his neighbor
had to stand there and watch him attempt
it pressure on pressure on
he pulled it off look at that because
you don't assume somebody's gonna make
that there's literally inches on either
side i'm genuinely concerned that the
white car behind him also has another
car like the one in front of him behind
him yeah that's that means he's not
getting he's right he's not getting
white cars what cars got white car needs
a little bit more out in the back that
car is not getting out
impressive plus also a shocker he's
wearing a brooklyn net hat too yeah
interesting that was the first thing i
know if i'd known that that would have
been a subject to conversation
wasn't the neighborhood i've be kind of
volley hold on
very impressive that's a guy who's lived
in new york a long time in parallel park
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here